how were you recruited into antifa back
in the days
so you know when i was part of the
anti-fascist movement uh nobody really
recruited me
i was already a liberal activist for
about maybe about a year and a year and
a half
and i knew a little bit about antifa uh
due to the music that i used to listen
to
a lot of people don't know this but
antifa actually comes from the anarcho
punk and like the
the punk subculture at least in the
united states uh in the 1980s
so listening to this music and kind of
following your history
i learned about antifa and in 2011
was the first time i put on the black
mask and it was to
uh fight against the national socialist
movement now the national socialist
movement is a neo-nazi group
pretty pretty spiteful people but since
i knew a little bit about antifa
i decided to dress it all in black and
just kind of show up and see what was
going on
and what did you learn well you know
once i was there i
i linked up with a lot of different um
anarchists and members of antifa at the
time and they're the ones who invited me
over to
more radical events i mean i attended
several different uh anarchist book
fairs in southern california in los
angeles and orange county
i went into this rabbit hole of
anarchist subculture
that i had only read about before now i
think the question is you said you
already were a liberal activist before
going to antifa how did you become a
liberal activist
well you know um i'm a mexican immigrant
uh i came to
the united states specifically
california in 2002
when i was nine years old and my
household wasn't all that political
sometimes they would be mentioning of
what was going on but i remember
watching uh univision and
telemundo and these two shows
they i mean their nightly's new segment
would always spell doom out for
everybody and i remember that uh
they they would make it seem like
republicans and like people who loved
america were my enemy
simply because they were at or because
they were out to get the hispanic people
i mean that's the the feeling that i got
from watching these shows
so i grew up with this uh in mind and
then in
middle school in high school i had
multiple different teachers who
told me that i needed to do something
well not just specifically me but to the
class that
we needed to be the voice of change and
then among them there was also different
teachers who
would uh instead of teaching them
teaching us their class or their their
uh
subjects would start berating us for
being conservative or if we held
conservative beliefs
is that your bio biology teacher you're
referencing yeah yeah exactly
uh i mean he wasn't the only one but
there is a biology teacher that i had
and i remember that um he used to yell
at us
and just there was this one lecture it
was about evolution
and he was saying how uh people who were
believed in god and didn't believe in
evolution were stupid
and specifically pointing it to us and i
remember he
used to say that like of course his
children weren't stupid because
he raised him to be atheist you know so
i it was
a lot of different seats were planning
and planning in me by several different
teachers
as well as the the the spanish media
that made me want to be active and
really care about politics
and the first time that i did something
that uh really really political was
around 2006 i think
and i remember that um there was this
republican
uh from wisconsin i forget his name i
write about him in my book
who introduced the bill to make border
crossings into the country
uh criminal illegal border crosses
rather
while obviously crossing into the border
into america illegally is illegal it's
not criminal
but what this bill would have done was
to criminalize anyone and throw them in
prison or jail or whatever
for coming here illegally as opposed to
just supporting them
well i remember in telemundo it was the
beginning of a new genocide and
internment camps and all these
uh these big things that were happening
all throughout the country
and i remember a lot of my different
classmates were mad about this and we
were marching around
our school this is middle school at this
point i mean that's basically
the first time that i did anything
overly political but from there
i i did things for anti-war things
against
bush as well as um
i also uh in 2009 to protest arnold
schwarzenegger who was the governor
republican governor of california
you know i marched with the teachers
unions that was kind of like
what it was at the time just protests
you know against the us army just a
bunch of
small little little things what what
what what were some of the phrases we
have a big
mexican community specifically mexican
community that follows the content here
what were some of the phrases you grew
up with
listening to mexican media or latino
obviously jorge ramos is a
sense of a latino community but what
were some of the phrases you would hear
you know what what are they going to do
to you
you said the genocide what were some of
the phrases you heard specifically in
spanish
in spanish ah gosh i it's kind of
difficult to to kind of remember i just
kind of remember like the sense of
of these different things it's fine if i
speak spanish in your show sure
you can't say what they said yeah well i
remember
specifically about foreign
president bush very hard about not
caring enough about latinos and
and just making it seem like he was like
this bad guy because he didn't want to
pass immigration reform
you